once upon a time quit and Tarantino when
Robert Rodriguez became friends and then
they collaborated to bring us the first
movie from that friendship this is that
movie from dusk till dawn
all right so when living in a world
where vampire movies are literally a
dime a dozen from dusk till dawn came
out when vampires were considered gross
among tweens Quentin Tarantino had two
movies out desperado was considered
literally the most violent movie on
earth and Clooney had not collaborated
with the devil to ruin Batman yet ah
those golden years baby
or at least bronze alright so long story
short Seth and Richard gecko are a
couple of criminal brothers played by
George Clooney and Quentin Tarantino
himself who take a family hostage to go
down to Mexico to meet certain freedom
and based on the fact that I'm reviewing
this movie because Halloween's coming up
that's not what they find down there
the family that they take hostages
harvey keitel who plays a faithless
preacher Juliette Lewis who pretty much
plays cannon fodder for the pedophile
and a bad actor who I've just never seen
again
so the movies pretty much like two
movies in one it's like a Tarantino
style crime movie from the beginning til
about halfway through so you having a
good time it's good dialogue and then at
the halfway point you get half a stack
from Salma Hayek's little dance and then
surprise vampires and then slaughter
these are not upper-class vampires
either wearing like three-piece suits
sipping goblets of blood speaking in
token ease old English now no these guys
rip off limbs heads and play guitars
comprised of body parts it's a true
story true in the movie anyway not in
real life that I know of but then at
that point the movie becomes a fight for
survival between these seven people and
just a legion of vampires pretty much if
you're not interested to see the movie
now you just never will be no I don't
even care this will always be my
favorite role of George Clooney but he
can go for an Oscar anytime he wants he
can go to played whatever tour-de-force
character he wants but I will always
love him most as Seth gecko from from
dusk till dawn
he is an absolute badass he's that
character that we guys watching a movie
and were like I want to be like that
when I grow up I still do that I don't
care I mean whatever he talks it's like
he has his gun out like this he scales
and he makes his threat and he pulls his
gun back like this to enunciate what
he's saying and he puts it right back in
their face then he does the Clooney
smirk that's awesome and Cheech Marin is
in the movie in three separate
related roles which is why I call it the
tale of three teaches but it ultimately
proves that if there's a Mexican role in
a movie Cheech can play it and the
violence in this movie is just it's
absolutely non-stop there's a lot of
exploding latex and egg whites in this
movie and I like how the characters in
this movie really call it how it is I
mean most of the time in vampire movies
they see crosses and stakes just killing
these things they see them come busting
into flame upon death and they're always
like what are these things can this
movie they're like holy [ __ ] these
things are vampires we are calling it
now it probably does not hurt that these
things straight up look like demons I
mean this is not Count Chocula they're
taken on here I mean these things look
like the worst of the worst these are
they're gross so violence old-school
vampires Quentin Tarantino Robert
Rodriguez a badass and Cheech
if you like any given combination of
three of those six items in a movie go
check out from dusk till dawn you'll
like it put it on your Halloween
playlist because from dusk till dawn is
gore tastic with three teaches one of
which if you memorize his monologue you
get points I'm just saying and stay
tuned tomorrow for another classic
review involving another classic vampire
movie more classic this time and you
want to hit don't you you want a hint
all right eating maggots Michael how do
they taste
do you understand me all right the
second part was my Jack Bauer that's not
actually in that movie but it's still
relevant but if you like what you've
seen here and you want to see more than
click right here to see more
[Music]